d'ailleurs ce n'est pas ma maison je ne
sais pas qui allait je suis entré comme
ça un jour et a eu personne seulement
des piments rouges accrochés aux murs
blancs je suis restée longtemps dans
cette maison personne n'est venu
mais tous les jours
et tous les jours je vous ai attendu je
ne faisais rien
c'est à dire rien de sérieux quelquefois
le matin jeux pousser des cris d'animaux
je gueulais comme un homme de toutes mes
forces
est cela me faisait plaisir et puis je
jouais avec mes pieds
ce très intelligent lépi ça vous emmène
très loin quand vous voulez aller très
loin
et puis quand vous ne voulez pas sortir
elle reste là il vous tiennent compagnie
elle
et quand il ya la musique ils dansent on
ne peut pas danser sans elle
peut-être dette comme les si souvent
pour dire des choses aussi bête que bête
comme ses pieds
gai comme un pinson
enfin ce n'est pas gai il est seulement
des quand il est gay est triste quand il
est triste hooligans et tristesse qu'on
sait ce que c'est un pansement
d'ailleurs c'est l'homme qui a appelé
cet oiseau là comme ça pas on peint son
pinceau
sous
comme c'est curieux les noms
martin hugo
victor de son prénom bonaparte napoléon
de son brunch pourquoi comme ça et parle
comme ça un troupeau de bonaparte
on passe dans le désert l'empereur
s'appelle dromadaires il à cheval caisse
et des tiroirs de course au loin
gallopin homme qui n'a que trop prénom
les appelles tu m'etonnes un peu plus
loin il n'importe qui est beaucoup plus
loin encore elia n'importe quoi et puis
qu'est ce que ça peut faire tout ça
dans ma maison tu viendras je pense à
autre chose mais je ne pense qu'à ça et
puis quand tu seras entrer dans ma
maison tu enlèvera tout et vêtements
tu restera immobile
avec ta bouche rouge comme les piments
rouges pendu sur le mur blanc
et puis tu te couchera je me coucherai
près de toi voilà dans ma maison qui
n'est pas ma maison
tu viendras